the Pantone color Institute recently
partnered with TBS to create their
latest color team cocoa orange it's the
first Pantone color based on a comedian
finally I'm having an impact in the
color matching industry team cocoa
orange is a proprietary combination of
yellow and red the exact formula can't
be revealed but it also includes two
locks of my hair teaspoon of baby powder
and a banana peel team cocoa orange
elicits this whole feeling of
spontaneity this impish sense of
impulsiveness and just a playful sense
of fun
Pantone went to great lengths to capture
the essence of what it means to be team
cocoa this affable and warm-hearted
orange tone encourages conviviality and
social interaction you know what else
does beer team cocoa orange can now be
applied anywhere and everywhere like on
our team cocoa orange billboard in Times
Square a team cocoa orange chair this
team cocoa orange fire hydrant and even
a team cocoa orange orange popsicle
getting hints of paper to keep up with
Conan join Team Coco